for the frita bonds quite a simple
concept you loan money to us over a
four-year period and in return we pay
you an 8% annual rate of interest with
the interest paid semi-annually it's a
500 pound minimum investment and of
course we throw in some food as well
so everyone who invests in the bond of
course gets a couple of free meal
vouchers but those that invest ten
thousand pounds or more get what we call
the Chilango black card there's over 80
of those people so far and that entitles
them to a free meal a once a week for
the duration of the bond so that could
be up to four years we've been going for
seven years now our first restaurant was
was on Upper Street we've been through
our share of mistakes we opened up two
sites that didn't work out for us and
coming out of that we became you know a
lot stronger as a team really sharpened
our site selection strategy focusing on
prime areas within central London we now
have seven restaurants and the breeder
bond will help us fund the next three
I grew up in Chicago which few people
realize is actually home to the second
largest population of Mexican to the
United States so to grow up in in in
Chicago and and not like Mexican food
you're probably setting yourself up for
starvation Chilango the term that's used
for someone who's from Mexico City but
for us the words meaning has a bit more
to it than just that we asked ourselves
the next question is why does anybody
want to live in a big city anywhere in
the world and for us it's about the
vibrancy the riot of contrasts that you
find in big-city life we strongly advise
everybody who considers an investment in
the burrito bun to speak with a
financial advisor beforehand before
making an investment decision we think
at the end of the day what we're
offering is isn't a attractive
investment opportunity but of course
that's for each and every person to talk
to themselves